Depression's up.
Anxiety's up.
We didn't know that comes from
a lack of innocence right now.
Hi, I'm a tail. I am 16
and I build a robots.
I'm Taylor,
I'm 18 and I'm really passionate
about singing in about music.
Hi, I'm Isabella. I'm
16 and I fly a plane,
which is a Cessna one seven two hi,
I'm fanny and I not going to see my age
and I'm a filmmaker.
I'm an Islam.
I'm 39 plus one and I am a film director.
I'm Jeremiah. I'm 41 I'm a regional
sales manager for a telecomm company.
Oh,
Laurie?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. Well I'll start. So
right now I'm learning every,
I like a new thing every day,
but like if I had a lot more years,
then by the time I'm like
90 I'll know everything.
Yeah, that great. Yeah,
just simple things like with learning how
people around you act that you learned
so much that you're, you're not
going to learn as a 10 year old.
I think it's Paris. I'd like to
say I feel I know nothing. I mean,
literally every day I say to you, I'm
just guessing. And the older I've got,
the more I've realized that everybody
else around me is winging it and they
don't know everything either.
And we're all just trying our best.
Like when you're young,
you're like, I know everything
about everything. You know,
from what I know to what, I
don't know. That's, you know,
those two things are just completely on
opposite ends of the spectrum. Right.
For me,
jeans today,
Lisa,
Teens Rock, but uh, you know,
it's forced on you and a lot
earlier age online for teen boys.
I mean they can find
horrible images everywhere.
Um, I definitely do agree that
there's a lot more exposure.
It's not like an intentional thing.
I don't think kids are just like worse.
It's just easier to get
caught up in bad situations.
Okay. Well, I personally think that
we're more innocent now because parents,
you guys could get away with
a lot more back in the day.
Yeah, it was, we were
naughty. We would do,
we did a lot of things my parents never
knew. But now I can, I can, you know,
check on his phone where he's at and,
but sometimes you go down
the rabbit hole where you,
do you think your kids are super
innocent and then you realize,
oh they have to snap. What's
this other snack? What's,
what's this other Instagram?
Oh I have a day when you don't know
about everybody has, you know, they,
I think you have to be more devious.
Well I mean this one time that you got
Instagram and all friends out of me,
they added
me to the first Instagram account
though chief parents don't see.
And that was slightly
disappointed in them as people,
but I didn't know you had Instagram.
See I got rid of it now.
But I think you have to give
credit to some of the kids. I do.
I think that there are some kids
who haven't got two Instagrams.
And actually trust is the biggest
element for me as a parent. I trust her.
Yeah. I mean if the question was
do you think your teen is innocent?
But when I say it,
teens, but I still think it's
50 50 you're saying your friends
suicide rates are up,
depression's up. Anxiety's up.
We didn't know that. Just from a lack of
innocence. Right. I think they were the,
I know three or four people in
my class that had those problems,
but they weren't spoken of.
I definitely agree that it's more I do
there,
no
you can't.
I think for me it's,
I don't know if you know how much,
I almost judge myself by seeing
all the people on social media.
Yeah, I do. Because that'd be
telling you I worry every day.
You don't know this when I'm on your
social media looking at all these other
things that people would be doing,
just hoping you haven't seen it
or that you're not affected by it.
So I worry about that all the time.
But I don't say anything about it because
this probably won't be surprised cause
he saw my grades from that year.
But in the off more year,
I skipped math class like all the
time. It was awful. So yeah. Does that,
you know,
one of the things that I don't think you
know about me is like I feel like I'm
always holding my breath. Do you know
I'm a lot softer person. I'm, you know,
when I get bored on my work conference
call, they tell you I doodle.
But I actually,
I write poetry and in a lot,
but I don't exactly like to talk
about it or put it out there.
I wish I knew more.
How was your day? Good.
Please tell me what's going on please.
I just want to know,
like I could tell you a lot more about
what I do, but it's pretty boring.
I like today on the way here,
you told me you're working
on a documentary when you
know I'm a documentarian,
like shouldn't I know these things like
this way I do for a living, you know,
I only have a couple of years
left before you go to college.
I really want to be a part of it.
Cool.
Yeah, I mean I made the decision to have
kids and I gave up that control of what
really for me, what I had to raise a
family and, and it's like my own fault,
but I got kids out of it. That's great.
I'll take the win on that. But you know,
I want more control in terms of what I
want to do and that's gonna make happy
and more fulfilled.
Why I feel like I Walmart control,
it's not, I wouldn't even,
I wouldn't say it's your
mom, it's, I just would like,
like to be doing more things by now.
There's so many things that I wish I
knew like for music and like making an
actual song and things like that.
So I feel like it's more of
that environmental holding
me back then like home
life
for me,
I really didn't feel like I
was a good trauma own life.
Now that I'm 40 I feel like I'm finally
grown into who I am truly as an adult
and owning it. I'm in charge of
my own life. It's nobody else.
I'm personally good with the amount of
controller have though I would like it if
you can show me how to control it myself.
So when I finally got to college and I'm
an ink pen and I can actually have to
do these things.
Yeah,
I think I'm currently very happy
where I am with what I control cause I
understand that there are some things
that I don't have control over.
And I think when the divorce happened,
having your parents break up as to
to see something as big as that,
that is something I have no control over,
but I knew that I could control how my
room looked, what I ate, what I wore.
I kind of embraced and took hold off
because I knew that that sort of,
I had control over.
I wish in my relationship
with the other side.
I don't know about this.
I think I'll go,
why are you shaking your head?
I think there's always
room for improvement.
Even if you're at like the best seats,
you always want to get a better
relationship with your parents. Got It.
I just,
I feel like it.
So I had kids when I was 20 by the time
I was 22 I had both my kids because I
was a young parent. I look at my
kids and I go, oh that really,
that mess that messed him up. Dang it.
They're going to remember that one.
You know, I just, it's like, it's hard
because I know I haven't been, you know,
completely perfect one. I wish I could
have a bunch of reduced but I can't.
So moving forward I want
to try to continue to work
on and get closer for sure.
Like at this point what like both like
me and you are looking for is just how
to,
how to have like the father daughter
connection still after high school I and I
think we both feel that
really hard right now. Yeah.
I also had them young and you know,
I'm divorced,
so single mom with two kids and says
pursuing the career while dating and I was
feel like, oh my gosh, I
did the whole thing wrong
because there I am going to Bates and I
do feel like it had an impact in them.
Especially my dad was my youngest.
Okay.
You were a lot like
you're always gone a lot,
but that didn't really change
the relationship that much.
I don't think you having today was a bad
thing or having me to really even know
you probably could have waited a little
bit more and there's, for example,
there's always still room for improvement.
It's not me saying that I wished the
relationship would stay where it was good.
I think we're in a good place.
I just don't feel right now that
it needs to be better. Well in the,
I don't think it's definitely not perfect,
but we're learning at the same time.
Improve it constantly. Yeah, constantly
checking in every day with each other.
We're always changing and I think
you have to s to work with that.
Yeah.
Let me have all the time.
I never knew.
Hey guys, Kendra from jubilee here. Thank
you so much for watching this series,
middle ground. We are so passionate
about inspiring radical empathy.
So let us know what you
think in the comments below.
Make sure to subscribe or follow us on
Instagram and we'll see you next time.
Okay.